Turing is called to order
thank you for being here today mr.
secretary this hearing offers an
important to start by saying I was going
to start with this oh thank you for
being here we welcome you I also want to
welcome Paul Atkins who is the newest
member of the Congressional Oversight
Panel and we are glad to have you with
us here today thank you I also want to
say as we get started here the panel has
agreed to keep their opening statements
very short so that we can focus on the
questions and we appreciate that you've
agreed to do the same mr. secretary
so thank you for being here this hearing
offers an important opportunity to hear
directly from you about the 700 billion
dollar investment that taxpayers have
made in the financial system almost
exactly a year ago secretary Paulson
told Congress that the country was in a
dire state Americans were alarmed to
restore confidence Congress quickly
passed the laws that created the
Troubled Asset Relief Program tarp since
that time public fear has turned into
anger savings have evaporated jobs have
disappeared and mortgage foreclosures
are now measured in the millions of
families and the billions of dollars
taxpayers question what tarp
accomplished when on an individual level
their financial circumstances seemed
more precarious than ever they feel like
they got stuck with the bill for this
bailout but they didn't get the benefits
in granting Treasury such enormous
discretion with tarp money Congress
expected an equal measure of
transparency and accountability
taxpayers have a right to understand
clearly what Treasury's doing and why it
is doing it each month the Congressional
Oversight Panel has issued a detailed
report in June we evaluated the stress
tests in July we examined the repayment
of tarp funds and after we reported that
the first 11 banks had repurchase their
warrants from Treasury at a price that
we believed was only 66%
of their estimated value the next round
of banks repurchased their warrants at
prices that were much closer to our
estimated value in August the panel
examined the impact of the decision to
leave troubled assets on the books of
the banks and how much risk that leaves
in the banking system yesterday
the panel released a report examining
the use of TARP funds in the domestic
auto industry and recommended that
taxpayers who now own substantial
amounts of both Chrysler and GM might be
better protected if Treasury would put
its shares in a trust so that someone
not in government could actively manage
them and make decisions about the best
time to sell of course
taxpayers are now stakeholders in
hundreds of financial institutions as
well taxpayers still want to know how
their money has been used and what
difference their enormous investment has
made have these companies been cleansed
of toxic assets the recent ARP was
passed are these companies better run
today than they were a year ago do they
treat consumers better now than they did
last year and the fear that no one wants
to have to think about what are the
chances these financial institutions
will stumble again or to put it more
directly are we going to change the
rules that got us into this mess before
it happens again again thank you for
coming mr. secretary we look forward to
hearing from you congressman Hensarling
thank you madam chair
on occasion I suspect we will disagree
in the future but I do want to thank you
for your public service at a time of a
great challenge in our nation's history
I would note that I this is your second
appearance before the Congressional
Oversight Panel since the president was
sworn in in January it is now September
I believe you have agreed now to appear
before this panel at least on a
quarterly basis I would ask you once
again to potentially reconsider
appearing on a monthly basis given that
the president has made a commitment that
his administration would be the most
transparent and accountable
administration ever I would think that
would comport with that goal a little
better we're clearly coming up on the
one-year anniversary of the of the ISA
legislation tarp has never really been
as advertised as we know a toxic asset
removal program became a capital
infusion program I'm not here at this
point to continue the debate on whether
or not it was wise legislation at the
time I think there are smart people on
both sides of that debate historians
will one day record it but I must admit
almost one year later I continued to be
concerned and I'm curious as to what
tarp has evolved into as of today I
think that many Americans share a fear
that I have that an emergency piece of
legislation that was meant for economic
stability has now morphed into
essentially a 700 billion dollar
revolving bailout fund for the
administration I am concerned that the
administrate the previous administration
crossed a line in investing in GM and
Chrysler something that this
administration continued to do I fear
that this administration crossed another
statutory line in favoring members of
the UAW and those re organizations over
similarly situated creditors and secured
creditors I feel like the administration
crossed another statutory line
and giving Fiat 20% of Christ or up to
35% a company that I understand was not
owed one dime and they will receive this
if they get produce a car for the
capable of making 40 miles per gallon
I'm having trouble somehow rectifying
this with the charge of taxpayer
protection and of financial stability I
continue to be concerned about the issue
of taxpayer protection although
certainly not all of it I need not tell
you that we have the first
trillion-dollar deficit in our nation's
history I need not tell you that
recently OMB had to change their debt
outlook they missed their figure by
about a third and we're looking at 9
trillion dollars of debt instead of 7
part of this is tarp recently the CBO
came out with their report that they
expect 40 billion dollar more of loss
and the Chrysler and GM programs so that
continues to be a concern and I look
forward to hearing from you mr.
secretary on particularly after the
president announced last night that your
administration has saved us from the
brink of economic ruin and I paraphrase
that don't have the quote in front of me
if that is true why do we continue to
need this tarp statute that many of us
believe is no longer about financial
stability so I look forward to hearing
your testimony I yield back madam chair
Thank You congressman
Oh mr. silvers yes thank you madam chair
good afternoon mr. secretary like my
colleagues I very much appreciate your
presence here with us today as was noted
the second time you've appeared and were
grateful I also wish to express my
appreciation to you for the support you
have given to her ballast in his head of
the Office of Financial Stability mr.
Allison has an outstanding business
leader and that's been a pleasure to
work with him these last few months
I believe Congress and the American
people should ask really three basic
questions about the Troubled Asset
Relief Program
first is tarp and the associated
programs of the Fed and the FDIC
preventing and/or calming acute
crises in our financial markets secondly
is tarp leading to the private financial
system once again playing its
appropriate role as provider of capital
to the real economy and finally is the
public as provider of funds to the
financial system through tarp and these
and these other programs receiving fair
terms when you last appeared before us
I focused on the question of whether the
public was being treated fairly
I remain deeply concerned about whether
inappropriate subsidies are being
extended in areas such as transactions
with weeks banks such as Citigroup
credit enhancements in the peep it and
the repurchases of warrants from banks
that have repaid capital purchase plan
investments however I believe that you
and mr. Allison have made progress in
these areas around the issue of fairness
as evidenced for example by the price
Treasury ultimately received for Goldman
Sachs's warrants a price very close to
this panel's estimate of their value in
our July report today I hope to discuss
with you the question of whether tarp
strategy is leading to the revival of
the private credit system with
particular reference to the continued
weakness of three of our four largest
banks a subject addressed in some detail
in this panel's August report this
question is tied to the important
question of what Treasury the Fed and
the FDIC strategy is for ultimately
withdrawing public support for the
financial system and you address these
matters in some detail in your written
testimony that's more today looming over
this conversation is the precedent of
Japan's lost decade in which you are
quite expert and the current talk of W
and L shaped recoveries despite
optimistic statements of the kind that
we saw from the regional fed banks
yesterday the numbers that we see tell a
tale of rising unemployment of rising
foreclosures of growing crisis and
commercial real estate which has been
addressed in this panels or earlier
reports rising small bank failures and
falling Bank business lending together
this data warns of the danger of a Vicis
a vicious circle that could overwhelm
both the stimulus and Treasury's
apparent strategy of hoping the banks
earn themselves back to health
I believe that Treasury the Federal
Reserve and the FDIC under this
administration and the prior
administration can take credit for
calming the acute crisis of last fall
another matter you address in your
remarks I also believe that the decision
to infuse capital rather than to buy
Troubled Assets that secretary Paulson
made in which I think you have largely
carried forward it was the correct
decision and has borne substantial fruit
for our country in the world I also
believe the stimulus package is a
critical part of the recovery plan
that's intertwined with these matters
although it's not really proper subject
for today the question now is are we
addressing the fundamental financial
weakness in our banking system or are we
hoping that if we close our eyes it will
go away now I look forward to your
thoughts on these matters Thank You
Commissioner Adkins thank you madam
chairman
good afternoon and I join my colleagues
on the panel and welcoming secretary
Geithner and it's privileged to be here
today and thank you very much for
appearing today and what I understand is
you know the meeting for the third
quarter of 2009 it's a privilege for me
to be here today to serve the American
taxpayers on this panel in our oversight
role over the Troubled Asset Relief
Program in the context of the current
federal budget and a talk today in
Washington of programs costing trillions
of dollars tarp sizeof 700 billion seems
almost quaint since we are in the
building named after him I'm reminded of
Senator Everett Dirksen's famous
tongue-in-cheek lying about the federal
government's spending habits a billion
here and the billion there and pretty
soon you're talking about real money
tarp is large and frankly the slush fund
aspect of it invites potential problems
thus Congress has set up this robust
oversight framework with a special
inspector general a separate audit under
GAAP and gas not government accounting
rules and of course this panel I take
this accountability and transparency
mandate from Congress very seriously
press reports indicate that you and mr.
Barofsky have resolved any ambiguities
in his reporting relationship to the
Treasury in favor of independence I
think that's an appropriate result of
the unusual nature of the program I also
understand that the information sharing
relationship between Treasury and this
panel has been problematic in the past
and you know perhaps can be improved
there's now a special liaison I
understand and Treasury assigned to work
with this panel so I look forward very
much to working with you all
and experiencing for myself the state of
interaction we're approaching the
one-year anniversary of the passage of
the ISA as representative penciling said
that set up tarp
since this passage Treasury has created
an alphabet soup of programs under tarp
and that does not include the other
programs of the Fed the FDIC and other
banking agencies several questions arise
how effective have each of these
programs being have some being more
effective than others has tarp achieved
its original purpose and mission what
are the costs not just in terms of
out-of-pocket expenses but also other
real if latent costs such as moral
hazard the authority under Issa expires
on the 31st of this year the Treasury
secretary of course in the past has the
authority has the authority under Issa
to extend tarp until october of 2010
will tarp be extended as that decision
already been made if not what criteria
will be used in making the decision what
are the conditions under which you might
make the decision the statute provides
only vague guidelines for example it
requires a quantification of the
expected cost of taxpayers of an
extension and that cost cannot be
quantified without a rigorous economic
analysis including direct and indirect
costs and that includes the moral hazard
as I mentioned so with that I madam
chairman I yield my time and I look
forward to the testimony of the
secretary Thank You Commissioner Adkins
now superintendent of banking for the
state of New York superintendent Neiman
thank you sure mr. secretary thank you
very much for being here today and I
will keep my comments brief as well to
maximum time for questions first I do
want to acknowledge Treasury's
responsiveness responsiveness to the
panel's inquiries on behalf of taxpayers
when we first met with you five months
ago you pledged that you and your staff
would be available to us and maintain
open lines of communication from our
public hearings over the summer with Ron
Lew and herb Allison to the many
conference calls and face-to-face
meetings we have had with other members
of your staff I thank you for your level
of cooperation and for supporting our
oversight work you also responded to
nearly 30 questions that I put to you
directly from members of the public some
of which were very
and candid these questions and responses
are now posted on the Internet to serve
as a resource for all concerned
Americans second although financial
stability has not yet been fully
achieved you deserve credit for making
substantial progress we are by no means
out of the crisis but there are positive
signs such as decreasing credit spreads
and the revival in areas of a
securitization markets nevertheless our
gains and financial stability remain
fragile addressing the millions of
homeowners facing foreclosure z' is key
to breaking down the downward cycle and
achieving sustainable results the Home
Affordable Modification Program is
integral to this effort but initial
results have been mixed
I intend to explore several of these
issues with you during my time here
including issues around delays and
service or participation and any even
service or performance of borrower
frustrations around eligibility
standards and access to account
information and the need to complement
the HAMP program with additional
initiatives to address foreclosure
stemming from job loss and recession
finally with Congress returning this
week it is widely expected that your
regulatory reform proposals will
experience significant movement and
debate I will be asking about your
vision for developing a regulatory
architecture that best supports consumer
protection and long-term financial
stability I look forward to your
testimony Thank You commissioner
please will will let's go forward mr.
secretary
um we received your remarks this morning
thank you very much they will of course
be part of the record so that we will
have more time to be able to question
you and and hear your answers I'm going
to ask that you keep your oral remarks
to five minutes of course anything else
that you wish may be entered in the
record mr. secretary pleasure to be here
again let me just begin by saying it's
my 16th time testifying before the
Congress of the United States and the
Oversight Panel this year glad to hear
you still want to see more of me happy
to come and try to again and I think
it's an important part of the process
and congressman enacted last fall didn't
just give the executive branch
unprecedent authority to try to resolve
this crisis it did create a
unprecedented level of oversight not
just with the congressional oversight
panel but with the establishment of the
sigtarp and of course giving the GAO a
its usual mandate for oversight we take
that process very seriously we have
examined carefully everything you've
written recognitions you made adopted
many many of the recommendations of the
oversight panels and I think they have
made our programs more effective than
they would have been so I welcome that
role and compliment you for the
thoughtfulness and serious seriousness
of your approach I also want to thank
you to me mr. mr. Silva's first what you
said about herb Allison and just say
that you know I have the privilege of
working with just exceptionally talented
dedicated people to Treasury it is a
good thing for about our country the
people who are coming are willing to
come work in government at a time of
crisis and bring great expertise and
talent you want to have working for the
American people people with the greatest
sophistication about financial markets
and these things they can do drive a
hard bargain in the interest of the
taxpayer and I think that team of
Treasury is doing a good job of that
just a few initial remarks last last
September of course we face the risk of
catastrophic financial failure and the
risk of a Great Depression and today I
believe because of comprehensive policy
actions put in place since then we are
back from the edge of the abyss the
consensus among private forecasters now
is that the US economy is now growing
again the financial system is showing
very important signs of repair
costs of credit has fallen dramatically
not just for homeowners for households
but for businesses as well because of
these signs of early progress we are now
in a position to start to adjust our
strategy moving from crisis response
from the emergency response to recovery
from rescuing the economy to repairing
and rebuilding the financial system to
repairing and rebuilding the foundations
for a future growth and as we enter this
new phase we have to begin winding down
in programs that are no longer necessary
and that by design by design do not need
are less needed less important as the
economy recovers let me just highlight a
few things that underscore this
transition we're in the midst of now
earlier this year we put a reserve fund
in the President's budget budget that
would have recognizing the possibility
we might need additional 750 billion
dollars of authority to fix this problem
today we believe that money is unlikely
to be necessary we've removed it from
the budget projections we are borrowing
less already than we expected to resolve
this crisis later this month the
Treasury's money market guarantee fund
will be allowed to expire earning more
than a billion dollars in income no cost
to the taxpayer FDIC's program to
guarantee senior debt which has
generated more than nine billion dollars
in fees has seen very very dramatic
declines in usage the suite of
facilities the Federal Reserve put in
place to provide liquidity to markets
provide broad support to credit markets
have have been have seen dramatic
reduction in usage so we are now at a
point where reliance on these facilities
down 80 to 90 percent from their peak
from swap lines for foreign central
banks to a backstop for commercial paper
the commercial paper market etc the
details are in my testimony when I took
this job the government had outstanding
commitments in terms of capital to the
US banking system in the range of two
hundred and forty billion dollars today
we have a hundred and eighty billion
dollars outstanding so that is a
dramatic reduction in the scale of our
exposure direct exposure in terms of
capital to the financial system in large
part because of this
excessive efforts to force a greater
level of disclosure and to make it more
possible for private capital to come in
and recapitalize this damaged financial
system the dividends paid on those
investments and the warrants who
received now total twelve billion
dollars and for the twenty-three banks
that the fully repaid Treasury has
earned an annualized average return of
roughly seventeen percent now all these
steps underscore our commitment to
unwind these extraordinary programs put
in place during the crisis as soon as
conditions permit at the same time
though we have to recognize that we have
to continue to reinforce this process of
repair and recovery until it is truly
self-sustaining led by private demand
the classic errors of policy and crises
the government's not only act too late
with insufficient force but they put on
the brakes too early and we're not going
to repeat those mistakes because to do
so would increase the ultimate cost of
this crisis not just the taxpayers
directly but in terms of the damage it
causes to the fabric of the American
economy now millions of Americans are
still suffering deeply from this crisis
still facing probably the most
challenging economic and financial
environment we've seen in generations
unemployment is still unacceptably high
the mortgage market outside what's
supported directly by Fannie Freddie FHA
is still significantly impaired
commercial real estate financing remains
strained small businesses in part
because they are more dependent on banks
have less options to access credit in
this difficult environment mister
winding it up and foreclosures are
rising significantly because of the high
rate of unemployment we're seeing as a
country because of those challenges we
need to make it clear that we're going
to keep those programs that are
necessary to recovery in place as long
as conditions require there's a lot of
concern that as things have improved
that we're going to let the market the
finish will go back to the conditions
that enjoyed before the crisis and we're
not gonna let that happen we've seen
dramatic restructuring and our financial
system already if you look at the list
of the top 20 firms in the country two
years ago a substantial fraction of
those firms no longer exist today as
independent entities the financial
statistics
but it's going to be stronger and that's
a fundamentally healthy desirable thing
for economy but for that to happen the
Congress the United Nations need to come
join with us in passing comprehensive
financial reform so we have much
stronger rules of the road and
constraints in place prevent this from
ever happening again hey I look forward
to your questions thank you thank you so
mr. secretary I was only about 6 minutes
in 19 seconds mm-hmm a year ago
secretary Paulson told us that we were
in a financial crisis because of toxic
assets on the banks books in fact he
came to Congress and explained that
Congress needed to give seven hundred
billion dollars to the Treasury
Department to deploy in order to remove
those toxic assets and we've had a year
to get rid of them does Treasury know
how many toxic assets remain on the
books of the banks do you have a dollar
figure for that partly because of the
stress tests we put the US banking
system through you now have an
unprecedented level of disclosure for
the 20 largest banks in the country
about exactly what loans and securities
they hold with a pretty careful estimate
of the potential losses on those
exposures you might face in a worse
economic environment that gives us a
much better picture today but the
critical thing to recognize is and the
reason we care about these toxic assets
and their losses is because they require
capital and we came into this crisis
with a thank you system did not have
enough capital to cover losses in a deep
recession and that was that's what
helped produce the worst financial
crisis in generations because we put the
system through this incredibly exacting
set of what we call it a stress test
with much more disclosure the banking
system today has much more capital in it
and that makes it much less likely that
the financial system is going to be a
source of headwinds a constraint on
future recovery if they had not been
able to raise private capital if they
were still left with too little capital
against potential losses then we would
be facing a much greater challenge but
the problems posed by those assets are
substantially
dressed by the dramatic improvement in
capitalization in the financial systems
so let me see if I can just pin this
down though you say for the 20 tests the
20 largest banks for which we have
stress tests you believe we have a sense
of how much is left in the way of toxic
assets on their books absolutely we have
a dollar figure for that well and I'm
gonna be happy to summarize for you have
the Fed summarized for you they put a
lot of detail on exactly very detailed
composition of exposures by those for
all the banks for which it's a stress
test was not run do we have any sense of
how much remains in the way of toxic
acid my compliments my compliments to
you for highlighting this question were
a country of 9,000 banks not just 20
banks that's right although you are
every day a few every day but that's the
sort of a necessary process of repair
and restructuring that we're going
through but and many of those banks came
into this crisis with more capital in
the big banks held but many of them also
had more constant exposure to commercial
real estate out of real estate stuff so
there is a lot of challenge ahead for
the financial system as a whole now we
had we did not we chose not to decided
not to put the rest of the US banking
system through the kind of exacting
stress we we applied to the biggest
institutions a lot of complicated
judgments went into that and so you're
right to point out that we are left
today with somewhat less disclosure of
that but the supervisors of the country
are spending a lot of care and attention
looking at those risks in those
institutions helping them work through
that and that but you're right to
highlight this is a significant
challenge ahead recognize that they are
those banks together those remaining
9000 banks together account for between
a quarter and a third of the US banking
system a lot smaller share so we are
probably likely as a country to be able
to manage through and withstand those
remaining pressures and we can do so as
much greater confidence because of the
actions we took to stabilize the rest of
the systems so when the Washington Post
this morning summarized yesterday's
Federal Reserve report the beige book
they summarized it by saying the banking
sector remains a mess
would you take issue with that
characterization I guess I would say it
this way I think the US financial system
today is in
stronger safe than it was three months
ago six months ago
nine months ago and on the eve of this
recession there is again more capital
greater recognition of losses and we are
in a better position to get through this
but remember this is just the first
quarter we're just starting to see signs
of growth it is very early and we did a
lot of damage to the finances of this
country and it's gonna take a while to
get through this and it's gonna take
longer to do it because we're gonna do
it right so I would not I would not want
anyone to be left with the impression
that we are not still facing really
substantial enormous challenges
throughout the US financial system and
where there has been improvement it's
been dramatic much more than I would
have expected at this at this stage in
the crisis but a lot of that has come
through the direct effects of a policy
policy to put capital in banks policy to
provide support for the markets that
were most damaged we do not have a
mortgage market today except for that's
directly supported by the government and
that sort of underscores the basic fact
that we've got a lot a lot of challenges
ahead okay thank you mr. secretary
congressman Hensarling I thank you madam
chair mr. secretary under the Issa
statute how do you define financial
institution I was looking forward to
this discussion and I think I understand
where you're going the statute was
written as you implied and your opening
same is really quite broadly and as you
also said in your opening statement my
predecessor the previous administration
made a judgment not just it was in the
economics of the country to provide
support for the automobile industry but
that it was legal and appropriate to do
so using the ISA legislation and you
concurred in that opinion obviously we
would not have spent a penny of
taxpayers money using that authority if
we did not concur in both those
judgments if you concur then clearly you
believe that Chrysler and GM are
financial institutions is AT&T a
financial institution I again I
understand I understand why it would
appear and if you look at the basic
plain facts of what I inherited in terms
of judgments like this
why it's hard might be hard to explain
why a automobile industry is a financial
institution but again that was a
judgment made by my predecessor
understand that mr. secretary
voluntarily chose to continue the
practice but I'm still trying to figure
out your legal interpretation of the ISA
statute and so clearly soon you don't
believe you're breaking the law so you
believe that Chrysler and GM meet the
statutory definition of a financial
institution so as long as the law was
written well of course
so again the question is is AT&T a
financial institution as American
Airlines a financial institution no no
no and no but but but congressman I
think it's important to recognize two
important things one is that the statute
I did not design this statute was not in
office when it was really there but it
did what was necessary for the country
which is to give the executive branch of
the United States broad authority
discretion to fix this and the fact that
we waited so long to make that authority
available made this crisis more damaging
and worse I don't know that one
important fact in reality in a crisis of
this severity a recession this deep we
have to do have to be prepared of things
that are completely we would never want
to do
mr. secretary understand that as you as
you well know Congress had the house had
legislation that dealt specifically with
the automotive industry so there were at
least some members of the House who
clearly did not believe that Chrysler
and GM came within that statutory image
so what I hear is Chrysler and GM yes or
Financial Institutions AT&T American
Airlines happen to be two Dallas based
companies are not so is there any
additional clarity and I believe one of
the things the markets continue to
demand is clarity of a public policy who
will you bail out who will you not bail
out and so I again ask you for some some
clarity on what is a financial
institution a congressman I don't know I
don't think we gonna be able take this
further I want to revise slightly how I
respond to your question about 18t and
American Airlines I think what I would I
would say slightly differently which is
I do not believe you can read the
statute today now things might be
different the future but I don't think
you can read the statute today to
justify action beyond the scope of the
actions we've taken this context mr.
secretary that the
legal interpretation of a statute
doesn't change with the passage of a
handful of months and the reigning time
I have in this no no no no I'd like
that's quite right in the sense that we
have to we have to pass two tests to use
this Authority one test is does the law
give us the authority to act and the
other is are those actions necessary and
prudent in the interests of fixing this
mess restoring financial stability it's
not the simple test of what mr. forgive
me unfortunately our time is is
constrain and I may have time for one
more question here leaving the question
of the definition of a financial
institution they're roughly I don't know
six eight major programs under tarp now
and I'm curious having been serving on
this panel for almost a year I think
with perhaps one exception I'm having
trouble discovering where Treasury has
identified any particular metrics of
success beyond financial stability
well I could all I can help I'd be happy
to help you I look at the capital
purchase program its purpose is to
stabilize the financial system the
automotive program prevent significant
disruption of the automobile industry
that could pose systemic risk to the
financial markets stability I'm gonna
have to stop you there congressman I'm
gonna be disciplined about time but
could I could I send this thing I think
I think that I'll give you I'll give you
20 seconds okay you can look at each of
these programs and this is the great
virtue of the markets we live in today
and you can see almost day-to-day
evidence of whether they are having an
effect in lowering borrowing costs
improving confidence in this ability the
system and one of the great things of
what you can see today just thinking
back to where is you can look
the cost of borrowing for businesses and
Families the cost of mortgages
confidence in financial institutions
where price of reason those things are a
good data indication of where these
programs are having effect and you can
see pretty impacts secretary but thank
you mr. secretary
let let me say we all have to be quiet
here or else we'll have to clear the
room and then we'll lose our opportunity
to talk with the secretary mr. silvers
yes mr. secretary I want to pick up I
think on the threads of your testimony
which I think flow very nicely into with
the real issues facing the country right
now which do include the question of the
unemployment rate a couple of weeks ago
in two parallel stories in The
Washington Post the following statement
was made on the front page the wounded
US economy and I quote has shown signs
of improvement in recent weeks but many
economists are accentuating the negative
bracing for headwinds you mentioned
headwinds that could cause the economy
it caused the recovery to be weak huge
swaths of the financial system have been
damaged which could lock consumers and
businesses out of loans for years to
come
next to that story was it was another
story about Asia it's you're smiling
probably read the same papers I do and
that story says Asian recovery has was I
won't quote it but the effect of the
Asian of recovery has been far more
robust than ours and a key factor and
that has been the relative strength of
Asian banks now do you do you agree with
this character with this
characterization that appeared in the
post of this of the circumstances we
find ourselves in important important
just things to start with you know in
the best of times we grow roughly at an
average of two and a half percent a year
for a emerging market economy in China
India Brazil Japan mr. Zuckert of Japan
was the Japan was the comparative yeah I
doubt that
you're gonna see more bust recovery
there than here but I would say again
you need to think about that relative
comparison but I I think that we are in
a position where it is much less likely
today
that weakness in the banking system or
on the rest of the financial sector
proves to be a substantial constraint on
the pace of recovery here the dominant
constraint of pace of recovery here is
the basic reality that as a country we
borrowed too much save too little live
within our means and the process of
correcting that pattern of behavior is
going to necessarily produce a slower
recovery for the United States mr.
secretary why is it in your in your view
that the weakness of the banking system
and particularly the three out of the
four largest banks whom you are I
believe correctly not allowing to repay
tarp money in light of your comments
about the fact that them for to take an
example the mortgage market isn't it is
it is a creature right now of your
efforts and secondly as you noted in
your written testimony that small
business business lending not just small
business lending but business lending by
banks is is going the wrong direction
quite seriously why is that not a
problem well no I think it is a problem
I said you know in a we're in a much
better position today than we when then
we have been and I think then we could
have expected to be so it's much less
likely today that it will be a
constraint but just a few observations
bank lending as you point out correctly
is declining but it's declined much much
less than it has in past recessions much
less than the Cline economic tivity in
part because we've been again relatively
effective in restoring some confidence
and stability the decline in bank
lending has been more than offset by the
increase in borrowing in the securities
markets so overall in a situation now
where mostly we're seeing is a reduction
in demand for credit again as people
improve their balance sheet save more
spend less but in less less evidence of
a substantial contraction in the supply
of credit but still early largely
because of the forceful actions we took
and the support will continue to provide
and so it would be not be appropriate or
prudent for us to infer from that sign
of progress that we're at the point
where we can start to walk this stuff
back wind it back completely right if
just to come back to that one sentence
and your written testimony which I found
by far the most interesting and no
offense to the rest of it is that
is it really a good thing that that
essentially credit provision has moved
away from the banking system to the
extended that it's going on particularly
with respect to the fact that most
employers most creators of jobs can't
access the bond market
it's the interesting question but
remember our banking system took on too
much leverage unquestionably so
inevitably the banking system was
leveraged is gonna have to come down
that was a necessary thing the
consequence of that is you're gonna see
less growth than lending by banks and it
is a strength of our system important to
the free tris ability system that there
are alternatives to banks in the capital
markets that actually works so if
there's weakness in banks there's an
offsetting source of strength and
vice-versa so part of the reform process
we're all committed to is not just to
make sure there's stronger capital in
banks much stronger shock absorbers and
banks much better capacity to absorb
future risk but that the securities
markets asked that back to another's
have a stronger more robust framework
because that'll make our system more
stable in the future my time to expire
I'll come back to you next round thank
you the Commissioner madam chairman I
wanted to start out by looking ahead I
guess if we could because I said as I
said before the authority under Issa
expires at the end of this year and you
have the authority to certify that it
should be extended with appropriate
justifications know the statute and no
one would be happier than I to see it
you know meet its end but according to
the statute you have the your
certification should include a
justification why the extensions
necessary to assist American families
and stabilize financial markets as well
as the expected cost of the taxpayers
for such an extension so I guess my
first extension that my first question
is have you made a decision yet I have
not yet sorry all right you know we're
gonna think through that carefully well
and that's why I wanted to explore
because this is rather you know for a
statute no offense to a congressman here
about the who didn't vote for it anyway
but but it's very squishy and it's
really questionable to me what like for
example to stabilize financial markets
you just said that
where you've been relatively effective
and restoring stability so when you
determine that the markets have been
stabilized are you comparing it to a
year ago and in which case they're much
more stable three years ago in which
case they might not be what kind of
markets would you look at us stock
market commodities international markets
the dollar I mean I I think all of these
things need to be carefully looked at
but I don't know if you've started this
process I completely the unity you
listed a range of important factors you
want to look at again what is the
capacity of the financial system to live
on its own now without these exceptional
support how likely is it that you're
gonna see enough repair and strength in
the securities markets not just in the
banking system for us to withdraw that
support I think that some of these
programs realistically going to take a
longer time from new work for example
the expected path of pro closures in the
United States is going to last for a
long time so it's very very unlikely
that we're going to be at the point in
the next few months to have said that
the housing market is at a point where
we can be confident that we can you know
withdraw these exceptional actions there
are parts of the credit markets and
asset-backed securities where there's
been very substantial improvement but a
lot of that has come on the strength of
the basic backstop we provided so we
want to look at a broad set of measures
of basic health in the system and we
want to make sure that people are
confident they're going to get this
thing in a strong foundation before we
strop because as I said again I think
the classic mistake people make is they
declare victory too soon they put on the
brakes too early they withdraw these
things and then the system has to go
back and build more insurance against
the risk of about outcome and that could
intensify the recession or reignite well
but contrariwise too you can also make a
mistake of leaving the crutch on too
long and the patient then gets weaned
you know gets too dependent on that
talking about moral hazard which I hope
that as you all do your cost analysis
here you have to take that into account
because you know I think that's a huge
usually undermining factor of our
financial system pletely agree with you
and I think you said exactly right but
let me just point out one thing that's
sort of helpful in that front largely
these programs are designed so that they
will be expensive
when things normalized and that's why
you've seen use of these programs
dramatically decline as conditions have
improved that helps mitigate the risk
that people rely on these things too
long
depend on them too much but I think you
could argue that for example the
warrants are you know even now
relatively under price I'm sure the
taxpayer is making a nominal profit but
query whether or not in relationship to
the humongous risk that the taxpayer
took a year ago you know is that
recoupment you know commensurate with
the risk that was taken but also I like
the way you framed that I think you mean
you look at two types of things and
measuring the effectiveness these
programs one is what was the directly
measured benefit to the taxpayer in
terms of the return on the risks we took
but that's not sufficient the best way
to measure the effective program has to
take a broader view of what did you do
to help get this economy out of crisis
into recovery and that's a harder thing
to measure right but still if you look
at almost any measure of cost of credit
confidence in the financial system
availability of credit concern about
risk all those measures are dramatically
lower and that that is the the the fair
way to capture the return on these
investments is to look at those things -
not just the 18% return on average we've
gotten on our investments and warrants
so that argues in a way for ending the
program no I don't I don't think it does
because again I think the art of this
and there's no proof is no science
there's no perfect thing the artist is
if you commit to do enough you make that
credible to people do you not going to
be behind always chasing an escalating
crisis then you're more likely to solve
it at lower cost if you if you
prematurely pull it back you're gonna
live with too much risk it's gonna be
more expensive in the future that's the
that's the basic central design of
effective strategy in financial crises
thank you mr. secretary
superintendent Neiman thank you mr.
secretary the new Treasury servicer
report on mortgage modifications
represents a I think an important step
in data access and accountability but it
also confirms and then the report just
issue
this week that there are wide
disparities among the rates of
modifications some firms as you well
know have not started any trial
modifications while many more firms have
really start racing in the low single
digits you held an important meeting
with servicers on July 28 to discuss
these very issues I was also encouraged
yesterday to hear assistant secretary
bars house testimony with respect to new
commitments that have been made in key
areas such as the speed of
implementation data collection and
borrower outreach now the report that
was just issued shows that there are a
trial modification started in the
numbers around 360,000 these would
indicate really only about 12% of
estimated eligible borrowers secretary
Barr indicated that servicers have
committed to increase that number to a
total around half a million trial
modifications by November 1 you know
based on that your benchmark of reaching
three to four million homeowners are at
risk are you satisfied we're on that
track have we set realistic expectations
and even more importantly is the real
risk and challenge in converting those
trial mods to permanent sustainable
modifications you just drive the facts
and the progress and the challenges
absolutely right it's not enough just to
have sent out 1.8 million dollars of
solicitations to participate a
modification which is the numbers we've
approached now or almost that level it's
not enough that you have something like
in the close to half a million offers
extended it's not enough you have more
than 350 households now benefiting from
substantial reductions in mortgage
interest rates you need to make sure
those are converted into things are
going to work over time and we are very
focused on making sure this program
reaches as many eligible homeowners as
possible two important things to point
out it is very helpful to do what we
just did which is to put in the public
domain every month detailed numbers that
allow the American people to see how
many people these banks are reaching and
I am quite confident that will produce
much much faster modifications much more
quickly because institutions do not
want to live with the consequences of
being so far behind the curve of what is
possible and helping families get
through this exceptional set of problems
the unimportant thing we're doing is to
make sure that we are going in after the
fact and looking at whether people are
denying eligible homeowners access to
modifications so there is a importance
called a second look program which
that's a softer form what it actually is
which is a a program of auditing to make
sure that they are not denying eligible
homeowners the chance to participate so
I think we're gonna this is going to
reach a substantial share of people that
are eligible but it's important to
recognize that this was just one part of
a set of actions we took to help
stabilize the housing market bring down
mortgage interest rates and those
actions looked in total have helped
bring down mortgage interest rates to
very low levels and have helped bring a
measure of stability to housing markets
housing prices housing activity faster
than many economists had forecast and
fundamentally it is that broader measure
that should be the ultimate test of this
program I think I'd be interested in
your comments about the continued
obstacles to effective in increasing the
effectiveness of service their
participation I'll do that in a
follow-up qfr but what we're you're
hearing and talking to servicers is
there there is still concern about
outreach getting documentation back from
servicers some creative approaches that
I've heard from servicers are because
people are not responding to going out
physically and visiting I'd like your
thoughts on other creative approaches
I've suggested in the past possibly even
letters from from yourself or even
ideally the president United States to
assure that people are opening their
mail realizing that this is not just
another creditor or notification but a
real response and involvement from the
from the government welcome those
suggestions and of course we are very
pragmatic we want this to work and we'll
take and act on any any reasonable
suggestion I think you're right to point
out for this to work people need to take
some initiative
and they take to find out how to make
sure they can get help but as you're
seeing 350,000 families today have seen
a dramatic reduction in the cost of
carrying their mortgage in ways that
puts more money in their hands at a time
when they're going to an enormous
challenge so and that the pace of that
curve is very rapid that's our time left
I just want to we will be holding a
hearing on September 24th in
Philadelphia on this very issue and we
would look for support from your office
to assure that we have representatives
from the Treasury and Fannie Mae and
Freddie to go over those very programs
that you reference particularly the
second look a good use of your extra 20
seconds down thank you
Thank You superintendent Neiman so I'd
like to return secretary Geithner to a
point you raised and that is that the
stress tests are effectively the tool by
which we have measured the strength of
the 20 largest financial institutions
and that's what gives you confidence
both that we understand the risk of
exposure on the toxic assets and the
overall projections on how stable these
these institutions are but the
worst-case scenario under the stress
test for 2009 projected average
unemployment for the year at eight point
nine percent as you know the current
unemployment rate is nine point seven
percent average for the year has now
reached eight point nine percent so the
panel has recommended that under those
circumstances the stress tests be
repeated for these financial
institutions does Treasury plan to do
that
I think there's important thing to start
with and looking at whether this was a
conservative enough stress test and the
measure of that is not actually
meaningfully in the forecast for growth
and employment that was framed as part
of that scenario the most important
thing to look at was the loss rates that
were assumed in the worst case scenario
and if you look carefully as you've done
at what the what
the Fed design and produce the loss
traits that were assumed in the stress
scenario were worse than peak losses
experienced by this country in the Great
Depression so they assumed roughly lost
rates in the stress test could rise as
much as nine percent we're now more in
the two to three percent range and if
you look at the what's happened over the
last quarter losses are running well
below that level and in earnings are
running substantially above the
assumptions so I'm sorry let me let me
stop there because you're the one who
put out what the appropriate details
were in the stress test as you'd expect
that's right fed designed but you're the
one who advanced it and said we could
rely on it and one of the featured
elements was unemployment and we all
know that unemployment relates very
closely to the level of foreclosures
which in turn relates very closely to
the value of the toxic acid but the
framing constraint and the stress test
was the loss estimates that were applied
and the earning estimates that were
constrained sand and those did not did
not relate to the unemployment forecast
so again that what matters it's not what
you advertised mattered no no no we were
again the great virtue in this
assessment was that we put in the public
domain for everyone to see and assess
for themselves what the loss rates were
so that raises the question actually we
would like to be able to rerun the
stress tests and I had understood from
conversations with you that we would
have enough information about how the
stress test is composed that reasonable
people could sit down build in other
assumptions and see how the stress test
would come out with these major banks
and in fact we don't have the risk model
and we don't have the data inputs okay
sorry to repeat that I'm happy to remedy
that and we're happy to spend as much
time as you like going through this but
that's again the I'll take your name I
need to need to slightly change the way
you framed it these were an important
improvement in the market's capacity to
assess risk and he's in
to shion's and on the strength of that
improved capacity you've seen a
substantial amount of private capital
come into the US financial system now we
never said it was sufficient there is no
certainty in life things could change
going forward but I think we have a
basis we happy to work with you on it
for people to independently assess
whether this these assumptions were
rigorous enough whether they need to be
revisited and and so let me ask the
other half of that and that is we also
asked the question about expanding the
stress tests to mid-sized banks and
perhaps even smaller banks in a somewhat
modified form is Treasury willing but as
I said we said publicly and I'm not
gonna change this view at the time the
stress test result that we were not
going to conduct a similar exercise bank
bag bank across the 9,000 other banks in
the country but what supervisors have
done 200 well again I think what the
explain what the supervisors are done
because this is their job what they have
done is apply pretty careful exacting
framework through the Supervisory
process to those instituted rest of
those institutions so that we can have a
better sense for making judgments about
the rest of strength as a remaining
system but it is not realistic or
feasible for us to conduct the for the
Fed and super to conduct the level of
detailed assessment required for this to
be credible for a bank thousand
additional banks thank you mr. secretary
oh I'm sorry congressman Hensarling
I thank you madam chair the secretary I
don't want to replay all the old ground
on financial institutions I agree with
you we've probably made about as much
headway between ourselves right on that
but I certainly think it's reasonable
for anyone to conclude that there is a
fair amount of subjective power that is
assumed by Treasury in deciding who will
receive bailout or economic recovery
funds under Issa I do want to start
replying Symone ground in my earlier
line of questioning because I'm
concerned the American people need to
know what are we getting for 700 billion
dollars today and again having been on
this panel I started reading from
Treasury's website on the purpose of
these programs and frankly with the
exception of the foreclosure
mitigation program where you offer the
goal of assisting 7 to 9 million
homeowners I think today we stand at
roughly 350,000 if my records are
correct I can find no demonstrable
metric of success by the administration
so can you enlighten me as you were
again I'll be happy to happy to walk you
through again like I do a Merton
testimony and the substantial reports
the Fed and the financial stability
Oversight Board has provided are we
happy to do it but I just don't think
what you're saying is fair the virtue of
these programs are you can see directly
not just how much money we're spending
where we're spending it but what is
actually happening to borrow and
condition those market so giving you
I'll give you an example one of the most
important things we did with the Fed was
this program called the term asset bank
lending facility be very brief designed
to provide a backstop of support to the
lending markets critical for small
businesses for auto finance for student
loan finance for credit card receivables
etc and you can see in detailed evidence
how much issuance has come with this
program what's happened to the cost of
issuance how much has been directly
funded by these programs rather than
indirectly supported by it in the mr.
secretary what you're asking us to do
though is draw in essence the cause in
effect happy to look at the statistics
in the economy but again coming from an
oversight panel here it's hard not to
conclude that essentially you have the
subjective power to invest 700 billion
dollars on a revolving basis on any
institution you deem as a financial
institution and that any program will be
judged as a success if you deem it of
success after the fact although I can't
find I would never claim that would just
remind you of two things the Congress of
the United States designed the Authority
Treasury was provided you have the
ability under the programs that you
designed to say here are the metrics
give you but again this is the great
virtue of this program you can see not
just the return we're getting when
people repay price we're getting
relative to the market but you can see
directly program by program what's
happening to
conditions only which is the ultimate
test of what we're trying to do that is
the great virtue in fact it can do
better than that well mr. secretary
means if what's happening in the credit
markets is the ultimate test and again
we can question and cause an effect you
know clearly the LIBOR is spreads one
month were incredible back in the crisis
in September of o8 by the time your
administration took office they went
down from 300 basis points to 20 basis
points now since your administration has
come into power apparently they're down
to 10 basis points so certainly that's
an improvement but it sounds like a lot
of this happened on the previous watch
well again I don't know what the cause
and effect relationship is a cause and
effect is difficult in economics and
Finance but it is much easier and more
clear in these programs these markets
than you can think in most other things
where we try to measure the effects of
economic policy and you are right to
point out that the actions taken by my
predecessor of course I was part of did
have an important effect in breaking the
panic in the fall of 2009 but it is also
true almost any measure of financial
health for this country in January of
this year was still in signs of
emergency so again the question is what
is the taxpayer getting for their money
today we can debate what purposes you're
getting we have an economy that you have
a financial system that is more stable
credit is more available people can
borrow at much lower cost and the
taxpayer the United States can see in
the investments we've made in the
banking system returns in terms of
actual billions of dollars well there is
no better measure of the return of these
programs and I think any we could see
and I would be happy to how about an
additional two and a half million jobs
lost the highest unemployment rate that
we have seen in 25 years mortgage
delinquencies and foreclosures up the
secretary it's a mixed report card but
but congressman no one is gonna know I
was very clear mica in my statement it
is only now we're seeing positive growth
for the first time unemployment is still
very high and could stay high for some
period of time we are not close
to being through this but on the
clearest direct measures of the program
we were tasked with executing we have
made more progress than I think people
reasonably expected not enough yet
though not enough and we're gonna keep
at it
Hey Thank You mr. secretary mr. silvers
mr. secretary I want to take this up
from a sort of different angle I think
one of your achievements clearly yours
not not the prior administration's in
the stress test was to put an end to the
fiction that all banks were equally
healthy I understand why that fiction
was indulged originally I don't think it
was done out of bad faith or for
anything other than the best of reasons
but it was important to put an end to it
however I think many of the
characterizations of success that you've
just indulged them with though with my
colleague are due to unwinding funds
that were given to strong banks and when
they paid them back they paid them back
at a profit and and and that was never
where the risk was embedded anyway I
mean there was always some risk but the
big risks were not there so I want to
turn to weak banks I hope you'll indulge
me in what may seem a little peaky a
little peculiar sort of questioning can
you explain to me and to the the
listening public what is a zombie bank
and why is it so dangerous I don't ever
use that term myself because I don't
think it helps anything I think the risk
in any financial crisis is the if you
have a banking system that doesn't have
enough capital they will have to reduce
lending and viable businesses or
families will not have access to credit
and therefore they will be forced to
shrink or go out of business or delay a
college education for their children
that's why the health of the banking
system matters and that's why it is a
good use of policy and and and and
financial resources to try to make sure
you bring capital in so you're not
living with a set of institutions that
are too weak to lend and too weak to
lend is it fair to say that those people
who like to turn zombie bank mean buy it
the walking dead meaning an institution
that is not in receivership or in solve
but is too weak to lend is that a fair
characterization of that term I think I
just said it again I don't know you know
I'm being less graphic than you but I
think you got the right concept okay
where are you going with this well where
I'm going with this is whether or not
you whether you like whether or not you
like graphic terms graphic terms
sometimes have the ability to clarify
things that otherwise seem very
mysterious the whether you're not you
like graphic terms and whether you use
the terms I just used or terms you used
in your view is city banks is Citigroup
such an institution today
no why this won't this won't satisfy you
mister Silver's but I'm not gonna I
can't talk in this context and I will
never talk in this context about the
detailed outlook for individual
institutions in our country any no
matter which they are in this case so I
want to return to where I began which is
that the best test of whether these
things are working is whether you're
seeing private capital private investors
in this country in around a little
comment willing to come in and provide
capital to those institutions to provide
funding for them and one of the great
virtues of the stress test was it gave
them a chance to make that choice and
they're they've they basically in a
sense voted with how how can you be sure
and I recognize the cause and effect
issues that you mum you mentioned
earlier are real in these areas but how
can you be certain that what you didn't
really do in the stress test was signal
that you the Treasury Department and the
Fed we're not going to further handle
the hammer the capital structures of
these banks and that and that they could
be invested in because there was an
implicit guarantee behind them even
though they remain at their core so you
know not really functioning institutions
or tea or is it's used a graphic term
zombies again you're right to point out
that we did a range of other things
besides just making it possible for
private capital coming these banks part
of that were the set of guarantees
liquidity facilities that the government
and the Fed provided together those were
important necessary things and they have
been helpful in restoring confidence but
again I think by any measure
you have a the system that we have today
is in a smaller but stronger capacity to
support the economy going forward and
that's the ultimate test of what we're
trying to do mr. secretary I'm going to
refrain because I think folks at
Citigroup may feel I'm picking on them I
was going to ask you about B avails in
order I'm not going to spend the time
doing that because you're not going to
answer and I appreciate why you feel it
would be inappropriate for you to be
specific with respect to particular
institutions those three institutions
are a macroeconomic problem right and
they go directly to jobs as we as this
panel has gone through the country
talking to people who are trying to
create jobs right we hear over and over
again that in various ways it depends on
what it is with its AG or with
commercial real estate or large firms or
small firms we hear over and over again
that the the the the system is weak and
the large institutions are not stepping
up mister Silver's that's our time
Commissioner Adkins thank you madam
chairman I wanted to go back to the
statute a bit because one of the other
provisions of the statute regarding tarp
is that the Government Accountability
Office is to do an audit and I think
significantly it's not under government
accounting rules but under GAAP and gas
which will be I think interesting so
they're gonna have to get to some of
these issues if they're gonna do a
balance sheet and a P&L statement and
all that sort of thing they're gonna
have to look at cost and whatnot so I
guess my question is first of all have
has this being scoped out yet as far as
the audit goes so where does that stand
I don't think I can do adequate justice
that today but I be happy to give at you
in writing with exactly where that
process stands I know that we have
coming up something we have to put out
in terms of a broad financial statement
of the government which will have to
include some estimates of those measures
but in terms of the GAO process itself I
don't know the details of that right now
okay so as far as when it might be
public I just can't tell you but be
happy to help you have them go back to
you or do it ourselves directly okay
another issue and you brought this up in
your opening statement is regulatory
changes that that you all have
proposed to Congress and I guess you
know having come from an independent
agency
you know I value the that sort of
tradition of independence from the
administration and earlier this year
there were reports in the press about I
guess I determined as maybe excessive
pressure from the administration
especially Treasury secretary with
respect to your colleagues on the
president's working group and elsewhere
yeah I saw I wonder where that stands as
far as you're concerned as far as
dealing with others as independent
agencies they're not part of the
administration of course and how you
view your interaction I actually believe
that despite what you read that there is
a lot of agreement across those agencies
on the core things we try to achieve and
I think on the broad structure and you
can say this in the framework for
protection and derivatives we put out on
resolution authority for dealing with
failed institutions in the future you
can see it in terms of the core
provisions on capital you heard us a
line a couple weeks ago
there is a broad base of agreement
across those agencies on the core parts
of reforms there are some areas though
where they would prefer that we leave
existing authority they have with them
and so as you've heard from them in
public the focus of some of their
concerns have been where we proposed to
take authority from them and put it in a
different place most conspicuously in
the area of consumer credit protection
where I think by any measure you look at
our system and it failed and we our
belief is to put in place a stronger
system you had to put in a single entity
both the authority to write rules and to
enforce them but that's the that's that
I think the best example really of where
there's still disagreement across these
institutions you would expect that the
screams nothing surprising in that well
people have vested interests and
everything else but I guess we can we'll
have another chance to talk about these
particulars later on with respect to the
programs under
tarp do you have any expectation of
expanding the list that you have now or
again what we tried to do earlier in the
year was to lay out a broad framework to
recapitalize the system and to provide
targeted support for the credit markets
that are necessary for recovery and as
many of you say we put out a pretty
broad framework of programs in that area
that was our best judgment at the time
about what it was gonna take we want to
have some capacity to modify and adapt
those over time to make sure they're
they're doing what they need to do and
to wind them down we deploy that capital
is necessary at this stage we don't have
any specific plans to substantially
expand out of the scope entities of
areas we would target but you know it's
possible that well looking at the damage
in the system remaining we might make we
might we might make that judgment but
we'd want to set a very high bar for
doing so because we want to be Emin
straight to you that that's a
appropriate use of taxpayers money in
terms of returns we're gonna get well
speaking of which one of the issues I
think that is still in question is
whether or not tarp is a revolving type
of arrangement whether the monies that
are paid back and then available for the
future do you have any legal analysis of
this yeah we in previous testimony we've
provided a pretty extensive responses to
the Congress and how and how we
interpret how we think that authority
was drafted and I actually think there's
broad acceptance of the view in the
Congress by the architects of that
legislation that the way it works is
this if a dollar comes back and of
course as I said substantial billions of
dollars have come back to the Treasury
from the financial system that goes
directly to the general fund to reduce
debt outstanding but but mister the law
is designed to still give us the
authority to use that if we think we
need to do it to help protect the system
I guess so I just want I would like to
see the Nebuta defenses okay Thank You
superintendent Neiman
modernizing our regulatory structure
your proposal includes merger of the OCC
and the OTS and I support that change
some including our nation's largest
banks however proposed going further to
create a single monolithic federal bank
regulator which raises in my opinion
serious concerns creating single
regulator as a means of improving
financial regulation relies in my
opinion on the faulty assumption that
regulatory consolidation leads to a
stronger and safer banking system in it
in itself in my opinion the opposite is
true such a proposal would increase the
fragility of a system by increasing
industry consolidation by eliminating
needed checks and balances and
subordinating the interests of the
consumer to the business goals of a
handful of mega banks my experience
multiple regulators yield better results
for consumers and fernette financial
stability much like multiple judges are
used in the Olympics to arrive at the
right score what are your concerns about
the proposals to create a single
monolithic regulator and and how
important was it for you in drafting
your proposals that the FDIC and the
Federal Reserve retain examination
authority to better inform their
respective missions of Deposit Insurance
and lender of last resort thank you for
raising that question that you framed
the choices thoughtfully the one of the
most important things we decided we had
to do was to eliminate the weakest parts
of supervision the system and eliminate
the opportunity for people to take
advantage of weaker supervision and flip
their charter or shift risk to those
parts of the system one of the principal
examples of that unfortunately was in
the difference between the standards
applied to thrifts and apply to banks so
we thought eliminating that was a
necessary absolutely essential condition
for reform if you look beyond that
there's less evidence that having the
federal banking system we have with two
entities responsible for different types
of state chartered banks alongside a
single federal supervisor would create
really meaningful risk of arbitrage in
the future in fact if you look at the
standards applied by bank supervisors in
general they were more evenly applied
and more effectively enforced so we
don't think it was necessary or
desirable to try to force all of that
into one new entity partly because of
the concerns about concentrated power
and partly because frankly we're asking
the Congress to do a lot in a very short
period of time and a guiding principle
it affected our choices were to say we
want to make sure they're focusing on
the things that are essential to do and
not on those that might be desirable to
some people but would not offer a
benefit that was proportionate to the
political difficulty or the practical
difficulty of doing it and that further
dramatic consolidation of bank
supervisors we didn't think met that
test but of course we're open to
suggestions and if there's a will in the
Congress and interest in going further
into the consolidation we would of
course be happy to be supportive of that
but I think you have to balance the
factors that you laid out in your
comments and you would share my concerns
over the role of the checks and balances
that I often use as an example the role
the independent FDIC and raising issues
the importance of the leverage ratio is
an important checks and balance in the
regulatory scheme but I think you're
right that there is virtue in multiple
pairs of eyes looking at these
institutions but on the other hand
competition across regulars creates
risks - we didn't get that balance right
we thought we've proposed how to fix the
weakest parts of the problem greatest
opportunities for evasion arbitrage but
of course we'll be open to suggestions
about a get that balance better I knew
my time I'm gonna pick it up break it or
form in the next round thank you we're
gonna have an x-ray I hope so right
thank you
AIG has received about 70 billion
dollars in tarp money about a hundred
billion dollars in loans from the Fed do
you know where the money went absolutely
and the money that and of course happy
to provide any any any detail that you'd
like to see on this the money in that
context went to help prevent default
help stabilize a very damaged
institutions that would have posed we
think very substantial risk of systemic
well maybe asking
maybe I should ask it with more
specificity was Treasury aware of who
the counterparties were that we're going
to receive payment in full on the credit
default swaps 170 billion dollars went
to a young they have hundreds of
thousands sorry hundreds and thousands
maybe thousands of counterparties but
I'm sure that the supervisor is involved
and the people the Fed who were at the
front lines of this stuff would have
access to detailed information so so
they knew who was who was going to get
the money the counterparties well I
think they could have known whether they
knew at the time I'm not sure they knew
that but of course they would have
access to that do you know if they spoke
with any of the counterparties in what
in what sense in any sense about what
about the fact that remember the more
account of many of the counterparties
are or you know institutions that are
supervised all the time they were
holding pieces of paper from a a an
entity that was clearly insolvent and
the question of the government infusion
of dollars there was going to make the
difference between whether they got paid
off in full or they ended up with
nothing right but but majorly you
finished so where are you going what
would you like what would you like I
just want to know what grand jury was
Treasury to Treasury have conversations
with any of the counterparties who only
profited I know I was not a secretary
you know at the time the initial mention
by wasn't that the president of New York
Fed and of course I was central to the
basic judgment we reached together to
prevent default by AIG I'm sure that was
the right judgment the time and you're
right to point out that that action did
help make the system more stable did
have broad benefits to stability the
system including the direct
counterparties but I want to say one
important thing because I think it's
it's in your per the premise of your
question the reason why I add you pose
systemic risk was not principally
because or significantly because of the
direct exposure of those institutions
those counterparties the biggest risk of
failure to the system was than the
damage you would have done to both
retail people who brought insurance
protection saving protection from AIG
as well as the type of risk you saw
Lehmann present to the system is whole
so it was a more complicated picture so
let me then follow up I understand your
point in the distinction you're drawing
we just finished our Auto report and
Chrysler and GM insolvent company AIG
insolvent company Chrysler and GM have
bondholders unsecured creditors secured
creditors and employees and they all
took big haircuts AIG had people holding
credit default swaps and they took no
haircut at all they ended up with money
from the federal government a hundred
cents on the dollar and I'm trying to
understand why those two are different
from each other but you've spent your
life thinking through these things so
you understand us better than many
people and it is sort of the tragic
failure about the regime we came in with
because we did not have the legal
capacity to manage the orderly unwinding
of a large complex financial institution
capacity we do have four small banks and
Swiss but did not have for anybody like
AIG and that forced us to do things that
we would not ever want to do but saying
that you couldn't find a way to pay less
than a hundred cents on the dollar there
but since you could find a way we would
have done that in a second if we could
have done that but the the the in
deciding that default by AIG would have
presented the risk of further systemic
damage to a very fragile system we made
the judgment to prevent default by
preventing default we helped AG meet its
financial obligations not just to people
that brought insurance protection
savings protection products but to its
broad counterparties that is the
consequence of that and if you think
through it not the same for the auto
industry well completely different
situation you're right but but if you
think through what happens when you let
default happen you can look at the wake
of the trauma caused by Lehman's default
to get some sense of the damage that can
cause and that's why we've moved so
quickly to propose broad resolution
authority give us better tools for
dealing with these in the future and I
appreciate that let me ask one quick
question if I can slip it in before we
run out of time and that is a year ago
we were worried about banks that were
too big to fail but in the last year big
banks have gotten bigger
while 84 small banks have been allowed
to fail and
some experts are estimating that a
thousand smaller and midsize banks could
disappear before this crisis is over I
just want to know are we more at risk on
the question of concentration than we
were a year ago you know I don't think
so but it depends largely on what
Congress ultimately decides to do in
terms of financial reform the only way
to deal effectively with the moral
hazard risk created by the consequence
of this crisis and by the
too-big-to-fail problem is to make sure
there are set of reforms in place that
make us better able to withstand the
failure of large institutions so we
don't have to intervene to put taxpayers
money at risk to prevent them from or to
provide for more orderly resolution and
that requires resolution Authority
stronger capital better derivatives
protection a whole set of cushions and
safeguards to limit the risk of
contagion spreading and that's why again
reform is so important and that's the
only way I think the system's safer
safer for future failure Thank You
congressman hazard
thank you madam chair mr. secretary I
continue to be concerned over the
precedent being set for the taxpayer in
our financial markets with the Chrysler
and GM intervention you are well
acquainted with the facts since it was
your team that helped put together the
reorganizations but gee and a GM
bondholders were asked to swap 27
billion in debt for initially 10% common
equity the UAW agreed to swap 20 billion
for 17 and a half percent of common
equity 9 billion in preferred stock in
the UAW through their Viva ends up with
55 percent of Chrysler they end up with
17 and a half percent of GM when you
talk about the success of your
administration in stabilizing the
financial markets I'm just very
concerned about how when senior secured
bondholders are treated less equally
than those who are unsecured and equally
unsecured creditors still we see the UAW
receives preferential treatment
Warren Buffett perhaps the most famous
investor in America said quote if
priorities don't mean anything that's
going to disrupt lending practices
abandoning that principle would have a
whole lot of consequences The Wall
Street Journal some would say that I
guess the investor journal wrote an
op-ed back in May quote by stepping over
the bright line between the rule of law
in the arbitrary behavior of men
President Obama may have created a
thousand new failing businesses that is
businesses that might have received
financing before but now will not since
lenders face the potential of future
government confiscation investors
business daily this undermines the
reason for buying a bond at all
accepting lower returns in exchange for
legal guarantees that in turn will
reduce the willingness to buy bonds now
I must admit it's somewhat anecdotal but
when I speak to investors I believe
there are hundreds of billions of
dollars that are sitting on the
sidelines but are concerned about not
knowing what the government policy is
concerned about the potential to
confiscate their investments
I have small businesses at least
throughout the fifth District of Texas
that tell me they can't get lines of
credit so I know there was a huge
stabilization by the time your
administration took office I'm not sure
I've seen a lot of improvement then and
I simply questioned what precedent have
you said and what is the impact for
financial stability in treating the UAW
so differently than senior creditors or
those who are equal you guys had a lot
of time to look at this carefully your
report provides a pretty thoughtful
discussion of the choices we face in
that context and the outcomes I know
you've had testimony in this before and
I understand the concerns you're raising
as you said many people raise those
concerns for some time but this was a
process overseen by a bankruptcy judge
that bankruptcy judge looked at the
terms of the agreement and reached a
judgment but what I was acceptable that
is a great strength of our system and
that was a lien though it was a plan
financed with taxpayer money under tarp
that's what's been but
I think you know you don't agree with it
you opposed this action which I
understand first thoughtful principal
reasons but we took this action because
we thought it was important and
effective to do in the face of this
crisis and recession and I think this
will be judged as an exceptionally well
design dramatic restructuring important
thing to point out is the scale of the
restructuring designed and approved
through this process went well beyond
what is contemplated by many people in
this Congress and waning sorry I'm sorry
we have a limited time here but another
aspect of this that I simply don't
understand is how Fiat is brought into
the deal 20 percent I believe of
Chrysler up to thirty five percent if
they will produce cars that receive 40
miles for the gallon I know the
president in the administration is is
passionate about their global warming
agenda we can have that debate but under
Issa I'm having trouble finding out why
Fiat who wasn't owed a dime but I don't
believe put a dime into the deal what
having them use tarp money to US
taxpayer money to produce these cars
sometimes in the future has anything to
do with taxpayer protection or financial
stability I just don't get it
iseman again I don't think I'm going to
talk about a concern and I respect why
you've opposed what we did and what
you're my predecessor did in the
automobile industry but we made a set of
judgment so what we thought was interest
to the country and I think we are much
better off today because those companies
were not forced to go into liquidation
and I think that was a prudent sensible
use of the authority the Congress gave
us Thank You mr. secretary
mr. silvers mr. secretary my my
colleague seems to be under the
misapprehension that you are a
bankruptcy judge are you a bankruptcy
judge last time you asked me if I was an
investment banker and I said no then
but I've also never been a bankruptcy
judge although I did recall after our
previous exchange about your resume that
the term banker doesn't to apply to the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York when
last night that would be stretching the
definition
it's not a bank anyway you but you're
not a bankruptcy judge are you no and
the the role of the tarp in respect to
any bankrupt entity is as a provider of
veteran possession financing is in a
context yes right and in a provider of
such financing make strategic decisions
about how they want their money to be
used right mr. Buffett would if he was a
debtor in possession of an answer
I assume the Treasury would as well we
did and we did so and what we thought
were the best financial terms for the
for the taxpayer and for the country in
that sense but again that those
judgments were overseen by a bankruptcy
judge all right let me move on the we
you've made some references in your
testimony to regulatory reform one
criticism of a program which I
personally believe is a pretty serious
and positive program that the
administration has put out is the
criticism that it doesn't really deal
with this with what structurally is but
went wrong in our banking system and
financial markets in that it doesn't
deal with the combination and risks
associated with Investment Banking in
particular proprietary trading combined
with commercial banking and insured
deposits I'm particularly concerned
about this problem because of to go back
to my prior questioning essentially
their zombie bank problem if you have
very weak financial institutions
particularly ones that think they have
an explicit or implicit guarantee
they've not been resolved they've really
they're really very weak that they that
the temptation to gamble is almost
irresistible can you comment on your
views as to how that this problem should
be addressed and will be addressed under
the administration's program again the
in some ways the most important thing
that we have to do is to make sure the
institutions more hold more capital and
a higher-quality form of capital against
the risk they might face in the future
you know capital is sort of like a rainy
day fund its resources they can draw on
if things don't turn out so well it's
probably the most important protection
we have against the risk of future
crisis look constraining future leverage
and risk-taking
make the system better able to withstand
the stress that might come if one
institution faces the risk of failure
and that is the centerpiece of reform we
laid out last week a comprar and set of
proposals for reforming capital
standards if you if you ensure that
these hadn't hold more capital against
the risks they take and whatever form
and there's more capital held against
the most risky activities you can it's
by the most important thing we can do
against the risk you're framing now if
we had adopted a strategy mr. silvers of
just simply guaranteeing the liabilities
of financial system not forcing
recapitalisation not conditioning our
assistance on the kind of pretty
dramatic restructuring then I'd be more
worried about the risks that you refer
to but that's not the strategies adopted
is it your view that an aggressive
proprietary trading desk is consistent
with then allowing an aggressive
proprietary trading desk as part of a
holding company that has significant
insured deposits is a wise form of
public I think you I think it is very
important to make sure that you hope
institute will hold a lot of capital
against all the risks they take now if
you look at this crisis and of course
we'll be looking at this for a long time
most of the losses that were material
for the weak institutions and the strong
relative to capital did not come from
those activities they came
overwhelmingly from what I think you can
fairly describe as classic extensions of
credit particularly where they are
backed by real estate and those basic
choices were which are classic banking
types of decisions and this is sort of
the tragedy of this crisis mr. I'm not
so sure about that I think if you look
at where the big holes came in the major
commercial banks they were substantially
I give one example I had this very
interesting conversation with one large
bank where they said you know we didn't
make any subprime loans and so I said
well how'd you get in so much trouble
and I said well we had something called
a capital markets desk and they were in
the business of repackaging other
people's subprime loans and putting them
on in off-balance-sheet vehicles do you
disagree with that as a characterization
of kind of how we got here maybe maybe
we're agreeing rather than disagreeing
and what you may call trading I would
call the
of credit and these were extensions of
credit but in any case the basic will be
on we know you want to make sure that if
firms don't aren't forced to hold
capital against the risky things they do
will be vulnerable again to a repetition
this question we're not gonna let it
happen
Thank You mr. secretary commissioner and
consol mr. secretary I'm glad that you
have a lot of confidence in capital but
I think even the capitals levels that
you're talking about would not have
prevented what went on last year and so
I mean I you know it's I think you have
to some of it is you know a bit of
flying by the seat of minutes I think
ultimately well no I think race
necessary but not sufficient credits but
it is central well and one of the
central things is really predictability
because as you were talking with a chair
about AIG I think if you go back last
year and this is a debate for another
time but when you track Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac and then what happened there
and then allowing Lehman ago but then
turning around with AIG I think that did
more to freeze up the marketplace
because people were uncertain than
anything else but I wanted to get to pee
pepper you know the public-private
investment program to find out where
that stands or to basic programs under
at the like in these legacies securities
program of course and then the loan
program the legacy securities program is
the only one that's really up and going
and I was wondering where that stands
how many purchases have been made you
know do you view these as viable in this
Grands great scheme of instruments that
are out there we are about to I think at
the end of this much are gonna see the
asset managers we selected to raise
capital to help launch these programs
close on their capital raising all
indications are they're raising a lot of
capital lot of interest soon after that
happens they'll be in a position where
they're out in the market buying
securities but you saw when the program
was announced and when the details were
put out pretty significant effect on
prices in those securities because the
prospect of financing and capital coming
in to help restore liquidity improve
liquidity in those markets so you're
seeing some positive effect as I've said
many times before in public we expect
there to be less demand for these
facilities than
was initially expected in part because
liquidity has improved and partly
because more capital came into the
financial system but I still think
they're valuable enough worth worth
going ahead with and if we think there
again there's a high return to the
taxpayer into the overall economy from
expanding them we'll be open to
expanding them further okay well I think
we can probably save that for another
day I know your time is short I wanted
to give mr. Neiman an opportunity as
well so thank you I'm sure so could I
just weren't very briefly if you're very
right to say that if you look back over
the arc of this crisis one thing was
very damaging the confidence was the
lack of clarity about whether the
government was gonna step in and
decisively stabilize the system but just
to be fair to my predecessors and the
other people who've been living with
this crisis that was there too but
largely was exactly but be fair to me
too largely that was the consequence of
the fact that until Congress acted to
pass the eesa the government I states
did not have the authority to step in
and provide capital and it was only with
that authority and the subsequent
actions by the Congress and the
President to make sure the additional
resources were available that we really
had the broad set of tools that were
necessary to help stabilize this thing I
think you're very right to say that
clarity about strategy matched by
resources and authority is central to
confidence and this crisis was more
damaging more prolonged in part because
of the absence of authority and the
constraints they put on the capacity of
the government to escalate and that's
something we have to fix we can't put
the country in the position where we go
into the next potential risk of crisis
recession with that limited set of tools
that's why resolution Authority is so
important well then I'll take back my
time a little bit just to respond I'm
not sure that your proposals will do
that actually and I think they also
raise other very dangerous issues
especially with this systemic type of
regulator and whatnot so you know we can
debate the authority issue from last
year another time but anyway again we
welcome a chance to talk about that
stuff more detail and you know we don't
claim that monopoly wisdom on these
things we expect our proposals to be
refined and improved as they works with
the Congress but the important thing to
recognize is that we can't
let the system where the country go back
to where things were with that much risk
and so few tools to help contain the
damage
mr. secretary we're down to our last
questions
superintendent Neiman Thank You mr.
secretary I applaud the administration
for taking the long overdue steps to
make Consumer Protection the national
priority with respect to financial
services I share this commitment can sue
consumer protection and I have seen
firsthand the impact of predatory
lending and I strongly agree with your
proposal to empower States and consumer
protection particularly by guaranteeing
that a federal standards would serve as
a floor and not a ceiling yet I have
some serious reservations about another
aspect of the proposal first I have a
fundamental concern about any agency
restructuring that separates consumer
protection from safety and soundness
these are not conflicting missions isn't
one of the primary lessons learned from
the current crisis at a loan that is
unfair to consumers when made is not a
safe and unsound safe and then Santa
doesn't that also that lesson argue for
greater integration of the two
disciplines into a holistic approach to
supervision rather than further
segregation so I would also question
whether it's absolutely necessary to
create a new and separate agency with
all the startup and unintended
consequences it would bring or whether
expanding the mission of an existing
agency like the Federal Trade Commission
which is a strong consumer protection
track record may have a better ability
to achieve the goals of regulatory
reform without creating new Bri aqua
seas and efficiencies and cost so my
question to you is what thought if any
was given to alternatives such as
expanding the mission of the Federal
Reserve Board or increasing the
jurisdiction of an agency like the FTC
that may be that they better protect
consumers and not create a new
bureaucracy we looked at a lot of models
and thought through carefully the
concerns many concerns you expressed but
let me just say it's startling
we have been living as a country with
the system where we gave bank
supervisors primary responsibility for
writing rules and enforcing those rules
for for consumer protection and how did
that turn out for the country
it did not serve us well enough it's not
a system that worked it failed in its
basic most basic mission the reasons for
that failure were complicated but I
think we had a test of the viability of
the model that combine those Authority
for Prudential supervision and consumer
protection and the judgment we reached
was based on that record of experience
over many decades several recessions
past crises that you need to put
rule-writing Authority and primary
enforcement authority in a single place
with the resources and expertise
necessary to do that job well now the by
by clarifying where enforcement
authority is we're not going to be
adding to the overall burden of the
system FTC is does a great job they have
a lot to do and the specific challenges
of getting consumer protection right
particularly in credit is as we've seen
very very hard so again this this
represents in our view looking at a
range of alternatives what we thought
was the best the best path forward but I
understand why you are a supervisor
Weiss why many supervisors look at the
prospect of a different model and many
banks are uncomfortable with the
implications of that change but I think
separating rule writing from enforcement
would not be a sensible strategy I think
the rules would be poorly written risk
of being poorly written and it would you
notic know acknowledge that the Federal
Reserve no late to the game did take
strong action with respect to mortgages
and credit card issues I could I
completely agree with you and they
provided a set of reforms and regulation
that began the body of important credit
card legislation the Congress passed in
the mortgage area - but you said the
important thing when did those rules
come but if the Federal Reserve was
directed to statutorily to report to
Congress to have a governor on the board
with consumer responsibilities and
experience would that not be an
alternative there are many alternatives
but we have to make a judgement together
with the Congress about what's going to
be most effective and again we've had a
painful experience about the limits of
effectiveness of the system we had which
gave those entities responsibility for
the rules and the enforcement and it was
a damaging failure now some of the most
happened outside banks the standards
were worse outside banks and part of
this failure the system was not to
provide greater protections in place for
non banks and that's the centerpiece of
what we're proposing that should be
helpful for banks not just bank
supervisors let me move on to another
area that's arguably not gotten as much
attention as the creation of the new
agency to protect consumers and that's
product suitability and effective
disclosures consumers and investors need
effective disclosures not just more
pages of print for example it may be a
suggestion of a nationally recognized
rating system to clearly communicate
product safety and complexity protect
perhaps along with a one page or two
page summary of key terms I often
compare this rating system to the rating
system used on ski slopes I'm a poor
skier when I get up to the top of
mountain I could not imagine skiing
without a green red or double diamond
don't consumers deserve the same level
of protection is this something that you
would connect with you and that a better
disclosure that kind of differentiation
is central to the basic strategy
recommendations we made and of course
we'd be happy to we're open to
suggestions about how to get it better
and in my last question excuse me we're
out of town agreement with our September
24th but I heard you and will try to
response respond of European operation
with respect to participation of
Treasury and Fannie and Freddie would be
very will do as much as we can to make
sure you have good representation thank
you thank you very much mr. secretary we
appreciate your being here we appreciate
your very detailed answers to our
questions and we look forward to seeing
you again soon
happy to do so again thank you this
hearing is concluded